Hello everyone, and welcome to today's class on transitioning from legacy production to
Unreal Engine.
My name is Brian Poole, and I'll be your guide throughout this course.
Here's a quick look at what we'll be covering today.
We'll start with you are here, and this will be a brief overview of a traditional production
workflow, exploring its pipeline and understanding its strengths and weaknesses.
Then we'll move on to where you need to be, and we'll define what makes an effective
next generation pipeline.
You'll learn how Unreal Engine meets those needs, and then take a look at real world
productions who have successfully adopted Unreal into their studios.
As we move on to our production overview, we'll break down a typical real-time pipeline,
discuss its advantages and challenges, and look at the tools used for data management
and team collaboration.
Next, in exploring Unreal Engine, we'll dive deeper into Unreal's technical capabilities
by examining project structure and Unreal's animation support tools.
And then finally, in final recommendations, we'll wrap up and I'll share some tips on
optimal hardware setups, best practices within Unreal, shot planning strategies, and asset
organization techniques.
Alright, let's get started.